Tchaikovsky wrote an incredible concerto
for piano and orchestra that nobody
plays because of the popularity of
number one but I love the Gil Elle's
performance of number two with kundrus
and one of the most inspired and
reckless things and you're going to hear
one of the few people that play the
second concerto many years ago I called
her and I said well I want to do
something on the cadenza because the
cadenza is truly part of virtuosity can
you do the second concerto I know oh no
no I can't I can't get that ready what
did I say yeah besides and it's later
she calls oh I just looked at it I'm
working on it and here it is did not
have lispy anism in fact it lists were
alive and he had heard the shukaku
second cadenza he would have said oh let
me change the passage work to make it
less awkward the way he did with the
Schubert blunder but it's very
orchestral and I think that's why it
works and it's lovely the melodies of
love love it is here it's such a piece
of job actually
[Music]
and
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]